- The problem is 98% of people
are sitting on 50/50
their whole fucking life,
which means they're zero-zero.
So when you're 50/50, you get one day,
and anything else is you're just fucking
sitting and bullshitting.
So fucking flip a coin, pick
the one, never look back.
(waves rolling)
(electronic noises)
- [Woman] Anybody out there?
I have a big life decision to make,
between two choices.
(electronic noises)
How do I know which way to go?
- You'll never know what the
alternative would have been.
You pick one and you never
ever, ever even consider
to look back.
- [Woman] Do you have any
quick piece of advice?
- [Man] What should I do?
Should I do?
- [Man] I don't know which one to pick.
- [Man] What should I do?
- [Interviewer] So what
should we do Gary V?
- [Man] What should I do?
- [Interviewer] What should people do?
- Until you go through it, you won't know.
I always play this out.
Let's say when you go to heaven,
they can show you what would've happened
'cause that's the only
way you'd ever see it.
Let's just say
what people don't understand is,
oh, Becca, you made the wrong call.
You should've went to grad school
instead of that opportunity
or this company instead of that company.
But you'll never believe it.
You should've went to
VaynerMedia and it was perfect
and you rose like the phoenix
and you were the head of all sound
and everything went great.
But then you had to go
to Virginia on business
and you got hit by a
car and you died at 31.
That's life.
(calm instrumental)
I passed on Uber as an investor
twice in the beginning.
If I did my normal 25, $50,000 check,
I would've made $400 million
which means I might've went to China
for a keynote two years ago
which means I could've
got hit by a fucking bus.
I really believe in that shit.
You just don't know.
You think you know but
that is not how life works.
So, to look at two ideas and
think you can practically
make a good decision is laughable.
Literally flip a coin.
(coin flipping)
Just pick the one that feels
better right that second.
And make it about you
because usually what kids
struggle with is the decision
they want to do
versus the decision that they
think they're supposed to do
based on the other voices.
You know, I think everybody
who's listening right now
if you wanna set yourself up for success,
ask yourself how much risk you've taken
in the first 10, 15, 20,
30, 40 years of your life.
You're gonna figure it out by tasting it.
Should I eat this cherry?
Will I like it?
The right strategy is to
fucking eat the cherry.
Right?
Moving is important.
'Cause you can change the course.
You can't overthink it up front.
Right?
You just can't.
Like, we're always wrong.
A lot of people make the wrong decision.
No matter what I say to
your question right now
and they're scared,
they'll continue to be,
they won't do, they won't put in the work
or they'll be fearful
or whatever it may be
and they'll lose.
I mean, a lot of people lose.
A lot, a lot, a lot, a lot of people lose.
The way to really eliminate fear
is by not giving a fuck
about anybody's opinion.
My losses are mine.
I'll deal with them myself.
I don't need your two cents.
You're losing plenty on your own.
If you don't give a fuck
about what people think,
you can do everything.
But the quicker you
start, the quicker you do.
I think people dwell.
And I think dwelling
is the wrong strategy.
I don't even respect my losses.
I don't even give them the time
to teach me anything.
I fucking look 'em in
the face and just go,
"Fuck you,"
and I keep going.
Think one time for one hour,
make the decision and go.
I don't wanna hear you
fucking complaining about it everyday.
And I mean that.
Way too many of you dwell on your losses.
It's holding you back.
Too many people make a decision
and then cry about their
decision every fucking second.
You made a fucking decision.
Own it, live it, sleep in that bed.
Shit's over.
You lost.
Move the fuck on.
(birds chirping)
Literally flip a coin.
Guys, the only thing I'm
hedging against is regret.
That's what you need to be careful of.
Regret's scary.
Regret.
And that's what most people do.
They build a life that leads to regret.
Nobody old and about to die
talks about what they did.
They talk about what they didn't do.
And you're in the best spot right now.
You're in the best spot you'll ever be.
Straight up.
This is the time to be most thoughtful
but everybody wants you to
figure out your life now.
Your parents don't have
their lives figured out.
This is the time to taste
and put yourself in good positions.
You could do everything wrong
for the next 10 years of your life
and be young as fuck.
And have unlimited time
to do anything you want.
(serene instrumental)
- [Woman] Thank you Gary.
Now I know which way to go.
(waves crashing)
By the way, it was tails.